this is the brand new update for ncape
so we're going to be sharing some
incredible new features all right so as
you can see we have arcad 27 open on the
one side of the screen and also endcap
on the other first of all let's jump
across to Arad and load up the materials
Library the andscape materials library
is filled with so many goodies so as you
can see we have bricks we have concrete
Fabrics glass everything glass is one of
my most impressive features ever to be
added in to scape or any rendering
software because glass you can just
never get right so by having a series of
available options for us here to use it
makes life just that little bit easier